Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians for being here with us today for our 40th episode!
40.
And really, it's not really 40 because there's other ones too.
Oh, sure.
That is not... It's not wrong.
It's right.
It's right because Mococo said it!
Sure, sure.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for the episode hype!
Right?
40.
BAU BAU.
Well, just because it's the 40th episode doesn't mean that the...
might not be new Ruffians with us today, right?
So, to explain what FUWAMOCO Morning is, it's a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face,
And help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
The 40th episode.
It's Monday.
It's Monday, the 40th episode.
You know what that means.
It means that there's been a Pero Sighting!
Okay.
Where was Pero seen this time?
Let's see.
Bowling alley!
You went bowling!
You're brave.
Especially because it seems like you went bowling.
Where's the Pero, too?
It kind of makes sense that Pero would be strong at bowling, right?
I mean, after all, he's pretty round, too.
I guess.
You know, he's probably able to put himself easily in the perspective of a bowling ball.
Especially when he sits there with all of them.
It probably helps him with his secret technique, right?
It's like method acting, right?
I don't know.
Is that right?
Maybe!
But, you know, you must be pretty awesome at bowling.
Especially with that custom FUWAMOCO ball.
Right!
That was the first thing I saw.
We hope you had lots of fun!
You know, hopefully you didn't hurt any of your fingers.
You know, get those munched.
Scary.
BAU BAU!
We hope Pero didn't get too yappy or annoying, you know.
Especially with that, he had a pretty nice score there.
Right!
BAU BAU!
That's pretty cool.
I wonder how you make a custom BAU BAU.
Right!
Love.
Lots of love.
And on the topic of love.
Love and peace.
Since the other day it was the hololive Minecraft Sports Festival!
Now, it was here, and now it's gone.
But, I think we can all say that many good memories still stick with us.
You know, it was a rather intense training period, you know.
With some very, very early morning practices back to back in the Northwest Passage.
But, somehow, we were able to survive and had an amazing time together with the Red Team.
And, you know what?
Despite everything.
In the end.
Red Team won!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Can you believe it, Ruffians?
We did it!
We're really really happy, but not because we won, but because we're able to get to know our team better and help them out and get to know our Senpai more.
We feel like we did our best.
So we're really happy!
In the end, it worked out.
I feel like we couldn't have wished for a better First hololive Sports Day.
Morning Ruffians!
We're really thankful for Mikocchi-senpai, Subaru-senpai, and Mio-senpai.
As well as all the staff who worked hard to organize and make it all possible.
As well as you, Ruffians!
You were there to cheer us on no matter what time of day.
Thank you.
Thank you!
We did it all together, okay?
Also, if you haven't listened yet, go and listen to the opening theme song that Mio-senpai wrote and composed herself.
So amazing.
Check it out, okay?
BAU BAU!
Good memories.
Already.
Only a couple days ago.
Right.
Yeah, check the opening out.
Yeah!
We actually have a bit of a confession.
You know, in addition...
To all the good memories and everything, there's one secret that I think helped lead us to victory.
And you know, Ruffians, even though both of us, we are both participating, right?
Moco-chan was the only one playing, right?
And we're both beginners in Minecraft, so it's not like I could really give Moco-chan hints or help, even if I wanted to.
Well, you don't know what we're doing at all.
No.
Yeah, I don't know, even- But the- I was thinking though, even if I was good at Minecraft, could I really do much to help?
I don't know.
Maybe.
Press this button!
I don't know.
You would yell stuff anyways, no matter what.
But!
But, Ruffian, I actually did lend a helping hand in the most intense parts of the competition.
And you know why?
That's because!
I became Moco-chan's hand rest!
My arm rest.
Yeah.
Hand rest, arm rest.
No.
Because sometimes your hands and arms get tired when you're gaming, right?
And just a simple chair arm rest isn't enough.
No.
So you know what I do?
I put my arm out to the desk so that Moco-chan could rest entirely of her arm on mine and then focus on what she was doing.
It was a true team effort by sisters.
Yeah, you know, because I'm pretty far away from the keyboard.
So it would get tiring for my arm to be outstretched for a really long time and pressing all the buttons.
So, it was just, it was done in secret.
Because maybe some Ruffians would have found it embarrassing.
We kept it a secret for your sake.
Yeah.
But it worked out!
It worked out!
It was just arm on top of arm, okay?
Yeah.
Arm a mountain.
Sometime I would be considerate and not put my full weight down.
But then, Fuwawa would be like, no.
I gotta push Moco-chan's arm down.
Yeah.
We did that during practice too.
Secret strategy.
I think it helped.
BAU BAU!
And well, the topic of the hololive Sports Festival still continues because, you know, it was a really fun event.
At the end of a special event, there's something that you kind of want to do, right?
Right!
And that's take a photo!
Yeah!
You might have noticed a bit of a change when we uploaded this photo to Twitter, but... Did you see it?
Did you see it?
You were surprised, right?
Right?
Well, actually... I was there for a good reason.
Moco-chan, do you have the photo in question?
Yeah.
There we are.
Well, actually!
This was all possible because Papa Puppy gave us a very old laptop.
Very old.
Like more than 10 years old.
And just so happens that Minecraft barely works on it!
So we're able to take a photo together!
It worked out well!
We're so happy.
We hope that maybe this will allow us to play on stream together in the future, but...
Logistic wise, it's not quite there yet.
You know, we have to find a way that's comfortable for both of us to play for long hours together.
You know, and there isn't enough room for even a laptop right now.
So we're still trying to figure things out.
But we hope that you'll continue to wait for us, Ruffians.
We want to!
You were shocked?
I'm sorry for shocking you.
Borrowed a toaster from Papa Bobby.
Exactly.
The game screen was so small.
So small, like smaller than a post-it note.
But we can probably figure out a way to change that.
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
I really hope we can play Minecraft soon.
But at the very least, it was good that we got up a little together.
Special time.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Last FUWAMOCO Morning, there was something a little bit more extreme than normal.
A bit of an extreme misunderstanding.
But, you know, it's a new week.
And that means we're going to start on the right paw.
And that's why... There's no misunderstanding!
BAU BAU!
We did it!
Good, right, Moco-chan?
Right!
Yeah!
Actually... I always get a little bit nervous when we have no misunderstandings because I feel like maybe we're just forgetting and there actually are other misunderstandings that we're forgetting about and kind of need to clear up, but... I don't know.
Oh well!
There's nothing, right, Ruffians?
Right?
I'm just being silly, right?
Oh my!
Wow. It's good that there's no misunderstanding. It's good, yeah. Ruffians!
You might have noticed that on our schedule for this week... It's a little bit different than previous ones. And it's not just because we're not streaming on Sunday for the first time ever, no. No, no.
And very funny.
That's because... All the hours are a bit different.
They're an hour different than usual!
The time thief got us Ruffians.
But not because we want it to be like this.
It's all because of the awful, the dreaded Daylight Savings.
Daylight savings time has come to an end, Ruffians.
So now, everything is funny.
We're so sorry.
We're sorry, Ruffians!
We know this is super troubleshooting.
We don't like it either.
Nobody likes it.
We have no control over it.
But it's a rule we must follow nonetheless.
We hope, Ruffians, that this doesn't mean that we won't see you for a while, right?
But we understand if it does make it more difficult for you to be here live with us too, okay?
We hope it won't be BAU BAU for too long, right?
We'll be waiting for you, okay?
Thank you, Ruffians.
Thank you for understanding.
It will be difficult.
It'll be back soon enough, okay?
Soon enough, you know?
And thank you for being here with us regardless, today, too.
BAU BAU!
Silly time.
I don't know why it has to be like this.
Don't like it.
It's the ruffest day, ruffest time of the year.
Just six months, right?
Just half a year, right?
Well, it's already been three months, so we should go by it fast enough, right?
Right!
It'll be okay.
But, onto happier things!
Ruffians, as you might know, because we kind of talked about it last FUWAMOCO Morning, Mahajama-senpai!
Mahajama-senpai has made her return back to streaming!
And today, she held a call-in stream for hololive members!
So you know what we did?
We gathered up our courage and we phoned in to chat with her for the very first time today forever!
Forever.
The first time ever.
BAU BAU!
We're so happy that we're finally able to talk with her!
We really admire her so we're so happy she's back.
FUWAMOCO-chan, you drew this special picture too!
Yeah!
I did!
You know what?
When we were able to chat with Hatsumo-senpai, we let her know that she's the person that introduced us to hololive when I kind of mistook her as a visual novel heroine.
We also talked about playing Minecraft together, or cooking maybe one day!
I think that'd be a lot of fun, but... How about we cook something, maybe?
No spiders, please.
Yeah.
We were just happy to manage to quickly chat with her before she ended her streaming night.
We were just in time, but we were really nervous.
And still super sleepy.
Because we had seriously just woken up five minutes before.
Seriously, yeah.
It was like, roll out of bed, go to computer.
Yeah, you know, my hair was still fluffy and fluffy.
But now it's like how it's supposed to be.
Thank you Hato-senpai!
Fukkatsu!
Omedetou!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, no spoilers.
Ingredients that are lost.
Mushrooms.
Oh, that's kind of plain though, no?
I was thinking like, Hatsuma-senpai's hair.
That would be okay, right?
Mushrooms, mushrooms.
BAU BAU!
More happy news!
Ruffians, we are really happy to find out yesterday.
Super happy to find out that our original introduction song, Lifetime Showtime, was introduced on VR!
On Suisei Senpai's radio show that she hosts on NHK FM.
It's a radio show about VTuber music.
Thank you so much!
This is FUWAMOCO's video debut.
Does it count?
I think it counts!
BAU BAU!
The reason why is because this time on this episode of VR, Suho Patrasam is a guest star.
Ruffians, you remember Pato-san, right?
Yeah, Patra is an amazingly talented and cute VTuber who wrote the song for us!
So we're so happy that she wanted to share it with everyone too!
Super talented.
Thank you so much, Patra-san!
Thank you!
Arigatou!
We're really happy that we were able to reach so many more people's ears.
If you'd like to catch the radio show, you can listen to the archive on the official webpage for the next week!
But...
We have a feeling that it might be difficult to listen to it if you're located outside of Japan.
Yeah, at the very least, we couldn't listen to it in the Northwest Passage, so... It might be tricky.
Let us know if you're able to have a listen to it, okay, Ruffians?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Well... Ruffians, it's the start of a new week. And a new week means a new challenge, right? Right?
Right!
And, you know, Moco-chan.
Last week, maybe we was a bit of a challenge in a different way, but this week, we're back to NATTO!
Moco-chan, yeah.
You can't escape this time.
Finally.
Moco-chan will be eating natto once more today!
I hurt.
My head hurts, and my neck hurts, and my face hurts.
No, natto's good for me.
My eyes hurt.
There's no heart.
Ruffians, this will be Moco-chan's 8th time trying to eat a FUWAMOCO Morning.
And you know, there was some progress last time.
Yeah, Moco-chan.
Good progress.
You ate and swallowed one bean.
Yeah, it was good.
Yeah.
But for some Ruffians that might not be too familiar with natto, natto is a common breakfast food in Japan.
And it's made of fermented soybeans.
It can be pretty sticky, pretty slimy, kinda...
Strong smelling, but it's really healthy for you too.
And that's why Moco-chan's gonna get over her fear.
I want to.
Her dislike for it.
And you know what?
She can eat it, become healthy.
Continue to protect your smile for many many years to come.
Just like me, Fuwawa.
Are you ready Moco-chan?
Not really, no.
Well, Ruffians, guess what?
This time, I found something that I thought might help Moco-chan.
I have something here a little bit different this time.
It's dried natto!
Can you hear it?
There's a bunch of little natto.
It's a dry natto.
It's not really a breakfast food.
It's actually a snack that tastes just like natto.
It has a natto taste, but that's because it's natto.
It's just dry, so it's not really slimy.
It's not really sticky.
It's just natto.
Isn't it waste?
No, it's a snack.
Dry natto, yeah!
So I have a bunch of them here.
And, you know, this way should help Moco-chan, should help you get used to the taste a bit more, I think.
Smells really yummy.
You're not careful, I'm gonna eat them all.
But today, Moco-chan.
You know, last time you ate one bean.
One actual natto bean.
Yeah, so I'll eat one bean again.
No.
This time, I'd like you to eat a whole handful of these, okay?
There's no zipper on the bag.
No, that's not possible, okay?
Moco-chan, there's no zipper on the bag.
I can try a bit.
This is white serving.
I'm saying I will try a bit.
Eat half the bag, okay?
No.
Give me that.
Okay, well...
Moco-chan.
I guarantee you the full bag is not one serving.
Let me see the servings on that.
It is.
No.
No, it's not.
The package is 14 grams.
And the serving size is 14 grams.
One serving.
I'm just asking you to eat half.
Let's half it.
No.
Half serving.
7 grams.
But, but, but, but!
First!
This time we're not saying thank you to the farmers in Tochigi.
We're saying thank you to the farmers in AMERICA!
Who grew the beans and worked hard to make them.
Okay!
I'm not gonna have them all.
No, you're gonna eat half.
Looking at them... Smell it, Moco-chan.
It's a little bit different.
Looking at them, they look like chips.
They look like chips.
They're still natto.
Okay, I have two of them.
There's like...
Moco-chan, smell!
Smell all of them first.
No, I don't want to.
I don't want to.
It smells really good.
It looks like it has, like, chip dust on it.
It smells kind of like... I don't know.
It smells like fall a bit to me.
It doesn't smell like anything.
It smells like chips.
It's chip dust.
Okay, I'm gonna try two then.
Let's try.
Yeah.
I'm kind of envious.
Choo choo choo!
Huh?
I thought Moco-chan would be like, oh they're just chips.
No!
Water!
Really really water!
No!
Please!
You should eat two more.
No!
Moco-chan, that's rude to the American farmers who made them.
What a chest dry natto.
It's not like they stick your slime in.
Even that's strong smelling.
I'm gonna have a bunch then.
At first, I thought... I have six here.
Let me speak.
At first, I thought, this is okay.
It just tastes like some sort of weird chips.
And then it hit me.
It hit me hard.
I think it's a very mild taste in comparison.
My body feels so hot.
It has an American flavor to it.
An America taste.
Not the usual Tochigi taste, maybe?
It has a strong umami to it.
Yeah, Moco-chan.
I'm exhausted.
I'm done for the day.
Was that rough?
It wasn't slimy.
There was no strings involved.
It's like it's concentrated.
I don't think so.
This is the American taste.
Well Moco-chan, how do you think it went this time?
Did it help you kind of conquer it a bit more?
Was it preferable to just go back to the normal Mato?
No, at first I had confidence.
And I thought it would be okay, and then it really hit me.
I do feel like this taste isn't as like... I like the tochigi taste.
This tastes a bit more... Mummified?
Mummified!
It tastes more like natto mummies.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Not artificial.
Just like mummies.
Natto mummies.
More successful.
You did your best today, Moco-chan.
I ate two of them.
Dry natto should be perfectly fine.
I ate six!
And I didn't have any water.
It's good.
That was an attempt.
Good job, Moco-chan.
I guess.
I did my best.
BAU BAU!
Well, let's take a look at some of our regular corners, Moco-chan!
Doggie of the Day!
Much better.
Now here's our Doggie of the Day!
De-den!
It's Kira!
Kira!
So cute!
But Kira looks a little bit upset here.
Yeah, I feel like this all the time too.
You know it.
Why do they get to go outside for such a beautiful walk when I'm stuck in here, right?
Yeah.
I feel like that a lot recently.
Staring out the window, look at the beautiful... Right!
It looks nice!
I wanna go out too!
But... I can't.
Yeah.
It's rough.
Yeah, but you know we're sure that your Ruffian opened that door up and took you on a nice walk moments or after, after the photo, right?
Right.
Right!
I'm sure.
How does Kira BAU BAU?
Kira Kira BAU BAU!
Like that!
I just want to say, I very much like how fluffy Kira is.
And the kind of caramelization we have going on.
Very cute.
Kira loves, loves, loves, loves waffles.
You better take her for a walk.
You better.
Don't even think of going out without taking her along, okay?
Don't think of it!
Yeah.
She wants to be with you everywhere you go.
She wants to be with you!
Yeah.
And that's because she loves you!
What was that just now, Moco-chan?
I don't know.
BAU BAU!
And for today, I went on a walk.
Ruffians are still going on walks despite the cold weather.
We have De-den!
It's a sunrise or sunset.
Such a pretty flower.
I think it's the end of the day.
And kind of looks like the end or maybe the start of civilization too.
This really looks like the perfect walk to listen to Mumei-senpai's new song, Mumei Tulen.
Right!
Such a good choice.
We like doing that.
Yeah, we hope that the beautiful scenery coupled with the emotions of Mumei-senpai's song didn't make you too teary or anything.
Right!
Not too teary.
We get like that sometimes when we listen to good songs on a walk too, right?
Yeah.
You just can't help it sometimes.
You can't help it!
It just makes you so happy to be alive and out and just...
BAU BAU!
Do we receive any questions from Ruffians this time, Moco-chan?
Let's see.
Our Question of the Day is... Do you have any rituals or habits that you do just before the stream starts or just after it ends?
This is a good question.
I think Ruffians, you want to know the answer to this question.
We do it!
We have a lot of rituals, I don't know.
I think more than the usual hololive member maybe?
But we wake up at least 3 hours before the stream so that our voices can kind of wake up.
You know, the barkers can get barking.
Sometimes it's been a bit closer to 2 hours recently, which is not good.
But we can't help it that much.
But we also like to make sure that we eat at least a little something beforehand.
And most importantly, do vocal warm-ups as well.
Brush teeth, wash face, that stuff.
Well, those just go, you know, you wake up and that's what you do.
Well, yeah, but, you know, wash face before stream too.
You know, and afterwards, we try to make sure to do stretches.
What do you think, Ruffians?
I think there's always new stuff we could add to our routine.
Do you have any suggestions?
But generally, by this time we know what, like, this minute we should be doing this.
This should be done.
Yeah.
Preparation work is hard, right?
We have to make sure everything's prepared, you know?
By the minute, so it's like, every five minutes we know what should be done.
Yeah.
Is everything scheduled?
More or less.
Schedule doesn't like... FUWAMOCO, we have a schedule, like a routine schedule that we follow.
It's not like an automated thing.
No.
It's just us.
Do a flip!
Oh, that would be good after stretching.
A morning hug.
Not quite, but before going to sleep, we go, let's have a good day tomorrow.
Let's make it a good day, okay?
A morning hug.
How about a morning high five, Ruffians?
Maybe not a morning hug, but... I don't know, a hug in the morning, isn't that... Wow.
In the morning.
I don't know, that's too much for the morning, no.
Too sleepy.
Morning High Five.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions today!
I want you to remember to never forget that FUWAMOCO Morning is a show that we make together.
FUWAMOCO and you, Ruffians.
So we always are looking forward to more Doggy of the Days with questions.
Questions!
I feel like, Ruffians, you have a lot of questions, but yeah.
I don't see that many questions.
Hi.
And you know Pero Sightings, it works too.
And you know if you post your question or your Doggie of the Day or your Pero Sightings,
Please don't delete them.
I understand, I understand.
But there's been a couple Ruffians that were chosen for it and then suddenly it's deleted.
Sometimes maybe you get a little bit shy.
It's happened a couple times.
We would like to include you because you're important too.
Please don't be embarrassed.
Thank you Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan!
What's our next stream coming up?
Our next stream we have...
The Kidnap!
It's the new Chilla's Art Game.
We're not really too sure what to expect.
I hope it's not scary.
You know, we've had more than enough training after all the spooky games we played through October, right?
We'll see how it goes and try not to get dogged up.
We're not gonna be doing the dog napping, right?
No, I don't think so.
I have no clue what to expect with this game.
Convenience store was different too.
I don't know.
Both could be interesting.
BAU BAU!
Let's take another peek at our schedule.
Tomorrow is a very special day, Ruffians.
It marks 100 days from our debut and also 100 days consistently streaming.
Every single day!
A lot of times, even multiple times a day too!
We hope that these 100 days have been special and fulfilling for you, just as they have been for us.
We hope that you'll be there with us to celebrate OK Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Yes, every single day!
Every single day!
Not a day missed.
Thank you, Ruffians.
BAU BAU!
That was today's 40th episode of FUWAMOCO.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
But we really want to say a big thank you for you for being here with us for the past 100 days.
And we are looking forward to many many more from here on out.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us for today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
BAU!
Go ahead.
You!
BAU BAU!
Fire!
Bad Cat!
BAU BAU!
Ametord!
Terrible!
BAU BAU!
Crayton!
Tsubasa!
BAU BAU!
Hayai, hayai.
Potato-saurus!
BAU BAU!
Sini!
Hanpai!
BAU BAU!
Dragon Warrior!
Kirarai!
BAU BAU!
Official Mouse!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Really?
This was FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!